transition. If you will not the
kind the thinking about I mean
gender I mean subject.
Was on the Seth Meyers show.
And let the front listen, it
sounds ridiculous. But if ever
there was a place that could
benefit from her fake laugh.
It's the Seth
Meyer show but read them all I
mean of of all the places in
the world, you know shows Joe
give you the fake laugh we're
talking about people dying
crossing the border to give you
the fake laugh which is talking
about World War 3 and anything
in between but young the Seth
Meyers who is actually
appropriate because they
benefit from a lot of fake left
are over there that is a really
terrible show like
Seth Meyers is about as funny
as an orphanage on fire on
Christmas Day. It's just
depressing stuff it's hard to
watch. But it was vintage
kamala in that you know
mountains of nervous energy a
lot of hypocrisy
and just weapons grade
stupidity and I want to start
there because common was
talking about on Seth Meyers
the border, you know, she's the
borders are she's in charge of
the entire Bush is bizarre of
the border. Has
kamala Harris. Bin
to the border, she's in charge
of parents or do we not know.
But it didn't stop her from
telling us the border was a
byproduct of the Trump
administration. And the fact
that there was a dereliction of
duty on the Republican side or
get around in or out here I say
it all the time and we're
living in the death of shame.
You know kind of shameless
sociopath you have to be.
To make Republicans the problem
at the border understand the
Republicans have made securing
the border. The center piece of
their campaign in
2016 in twenty-twenty again
here in the midterms
it's like the one thing they
talk about the most like you
know if you go to see like
jumbo umba you're always going
here I get knocked down, but I
get up again because there one
song. The Republicans when it
comes to the border, almost
sound like a one hit wonder
because they recognize how
primal it is to every single
man woman and child living in
this country. They talk about
it. A lot. Support the men and
women in uniform support the
border, stop spending. Cut
taxes. These are the only
things ever hear out of their
mouths. But here's kamala
trying to pass the Bok put on
the old QB jersey got on their
huddle. 28 and here she is
passing the buck on immigration
clip, 25.
>> Absolute dereliction of duty
if you see a problem
and if we agree that that we
need to address it. Then if
you're a leader participate in
the solution.
Right.
>> She is a fraud and a phony a
woman without a
moral core, a regular to face
mealy mouth politician who
swings with the win.
>> She thinks it's a
dereliction of duty. If you see
a problem. And the need to
address it.
>> And you don't participate
ought to be ashamed. Of
yourself, you know you are as a
border czar. And you haven't
bin to the border.
Okay you don't talk to anyone
about dereliction of duty
that's been made it's. Okay I
imagine that you're in charge
of driving the fire truck
ladder company, 22 that's your
job you drive the fire truck.
But 2 years have gone by and
you haven't showed up to
a single solitary fire not
once.
But you have the nerve to get
on TV and say the other side is
a dereliction of duty kamala
Harris you know sad are you
kidding me, but that's
embarrassing aged heard on the
inside a little bit.
It will throw open the mouth, I
mean just felt like as you say
it like it's a dereliction of
duty by the Republic, a good
book.
And here she is seeing the last
administration they've broken
immigration system that's what
they did clip 26.
>> When we first came in
office, the first bill that we
proposed was for a pathway
for citizenship. It was to fix
a broken immigration system
which was broken under the
previous administration
participate in the solution
because we are
offering solutions. But instead
this gamesmanship. With real
human beings who trust us.
>> I don't have any friends.
>> I mean what a loser
okay.
>> This game's been ship with
real human beings talking about
people getting on air
conditioned buses and shipped
to other states. And she says
it is if that
worse alternative. Then you
know allowing them to drown and
rivers as she has
allowing them to suffocate a
tractor trailers as she has
allowing 30% of the women
across this border illegally to
get sexually assaulted as she
has somehow it's the
gamesmanship on the Republican
side you've got to be worried
about right now.
>> Is what she wants you to
understand comma is a lying
sociopath fact check click in
actual social path though.
Okay when you really think
about her ability to get in
front of a camera
and address millions of people
probably that millions of
people with Seth Meyers but her
willingness to get in front of
a camera and address dozens of
people.
And say the Republicans of the
problem, it's
Republican gamesmanship
understand the Republican
gamesmanship which is
relocating migrants to
sanctuary cities. You know the
sanctuary city means it means
we're willing to take in the
migrants, no one is a legal in
our city come on down.
Until they came on down and the
Democrats alike all No can't be
coming on down.
>> The strain on our resources.
This humanitarian crisis.
What do you mean
air-conditioned buses we can
have air condition by
I liked it better when they
were back in the rivers whose
idea was the buses. It's
inhumane I tell you. Time was
you could Jim 83 people under
the floorboards of a tractor
trailer, those were the good
old days. Now they got American
dish and they're coming up put
them in hotels, what you mean,
okay, it's
such fraud.
>> Democrats are so full of
Crabb they really are and here
she is she saying the migrant
busing is political theater
clip, 27.
>> I mean we're talking about
people who have fled great harm
they fled great harm. And they
are coming here seeking refuge.
Talk about
political theater. I mean that
playing games of people's lives
on with their lives. You know
there are mothers with sleeping
babies getting off those buses.
>> This mothers with sleeping
babies coming off those buses
again, not ideal. But you know
what else they're doing with
those sleeping babies. Waiting
across the river and drowning.
OK getting smuggled by
drug cartels that sexually
assault them force them the
meal drugs into the country.
You know I child separation
exist in our Southern border.
Okay began under George W Bush.
It continued under barack obama
I don't see you doing any
better in the beauty department
and it went on to Donald Trump.
And of course, okay they kept
that policy in place after
Biden won the election. I don't
remember that ever happening,
but it did okay Biden's in
charge right now unfortunately.
And understand that the reason
they separate families at the
border is because 90% of the
time the kid isn't with his
family. The kid is in with his
legal guardian. He is with an
asylum seeker who knows he has
a much higher chance of getting
into the country. If he's
accompanied by
a minor he's a lousy bad, but
he's right so understand, okay,
child separation is there
to protect the child to make
sure he is not with someone
taking advantage abusing him,
okay that's why it exists okay
to this day. You don't have a
single solitary story
of a family that was separated
at the border and never got
back together. It's a voter
suppression you can show me one
legal voter
who was denied the right to
vote it doesn't exist, you know
the old adage when you have the
fact pound the faction got
nothing pound the table.
The Democrats are always
pounding the table
when it comes to stupid stories
like this put up are set up,
but they don't shut up.
Let's talk about playing games
with people's lives yet
incentivizing them to come here
illegally. Is playing games
with their lives.
Okay with the last
administration tried to do was
secure the border.
You don't have to like them.
I don't care I'm not a
recruiter for the Republican
Party. But you understand
that the Democrats voted for
border wall funding, okay, they
voted for it under barack obama
they voted for it under George
W Bush. Why because
the border is the front door to
the House,
okay look at it like the front
door to your house you shut the
door and lock it at night
because you want to know who's
coming in or out of the House.
It's not because you're racist
it's because you're not an
idiot. But in this instance, we
have it's in charge complete
and total. I mean 100% more ons
I agree with that OK running
this administration.
And they like to pivot to
things that talk on your
heartstrings both people's
lives, you're playing games
>> You know how severe that day
and why do they want to do that
they'd rather you be matter.
And a guy like Ron Greg Abbott
then the matter at them, the
ones who are green-lighting the
drug cartels
to turn our border into a
15 billion dollar trafficking
industry the the the southern
border of our country
is worth 15 billion dollars in
commerce to drug traffickers
right now. Okay after the
previous administration had
implemented a remain in Mexico
policy that completely took the
teeth out of the cartels
because you understand
when asylum. Seekers had to
remain in Mexico until they got
into the country.
The cartels couldn't guarantee
them safe passage into
the country. Okay by repealing
that policy because it was Ray
says.
>> We've got to be building
bridges not walls.
>> Such performance stupidity
but by repealing that policy.
It allowed everybody who got
quarter Southern border to come
into the You hear legal fine.
All right, let's just process,
yeah you're going to trial and
6 months. And you better come
back for that trial to make
sure your asylum cases granted.
90% of the people who cross the
border illegally don't show up
their asylum hearing why would
you you're already in the
country. Why are you going to
show up for a legal hearing
that could result in you
leaving the country these
people already broke the law
wants to get in. They're not
going to start following it now
that they're here illegally do
understand. And by
taking away policies like oh I
don't know stopping a border
wall ending remain in Mexico,
not enforcing title 42.
The Democrats sent a message
they turned our Southern border
into the college bar that
doesn't check I D
you all remember go to a bar in
college when you are under age
and you're like nah to go to
this place you can get in with
like a library card.
All of a sudden the line was
around the block because all of
the people who should be in
bars knew there was a way in
and they started showing up to
them, hey this is great.
And that's the people at the
southern border, great empathy
for them. They're fleeing real
food security real problems
real oppression, not fake
American stuff. Okay, but
understand there's a legal way
to do this so they don't
strained the resources of our
system. But more importantly
for being honest
so they don't drowned in rivers
suffocating tractor trailers
and get sexually assaulted by
drug cartels things kamala
Harris doesn't really care
about in for being honest whic